let's relive Sunday for a second how'd
you celebrate the rest of your night
well I went out with this whole crew
that you'll see taking photos in a
heartbeat but we call each other a band
because we've just we've become
something even tighter than that somehow
not somehow because of this film it is
it just brought us together it
galvanized us from day one and I've
never had this experience where I've got
this close to a group of actors before
yeah and we are shipping you and Lucy so
hard what is it like kind of sharing
this experience with her specifically
well it's it's honestly it's the same as
sharing it with the boys as well because
we're on the same text chain together
and we talk every day it's a it's a
group we were just talking about
celebrating her birthday and everybody's
gonna fly out to London to do that how
many times have you seen sanctuary I
asked our producers to watch sing Street
to make sure we were gonna live up to
that film I love that film okay
so you had to relive the Nicole Kidman
moment on Jimmy Kimmel next time you see
her next award show what are you gonna
say to her we may or may not have
something planned out alright how about
that yeah she's she's been a friend for
a long time that's why the whole thing I
find absolutely ridiculous in hilarious
but I'm having a laugh about it you love
it because it's the most relatable
moment yeah no it's a human moment I
mean it's I gotta say I got up there and
I was in such a daze I don't even know
how I put together a collection of words
that sounded coherent and then all of a
sudden I went backstage and they said
you got to stay put your category for
Best Picture is coming up and all of a
sudden I heard Bohemian Rhapsody
announced and
now just sent me into even more shock so
the fact that I knew Nicole for a second
was like oh here's a bit of safety and
then of course she didn't see me and it
was as simple as that but loved Nicole I
admire her respect her and she is so
done earth and so cool so it's if we're
having a laugh about it right now thank
you so much
[Music]